the Joe Rogan experience research shows
that when you know somebody say who's
gay you're less likely to be homophobic
just the exposure to them and so the
effect part of the effective cause of
moral progress is bottom-up now
sometimes you have to pass laws to get
people to change like to abolish slavery
in the United States we needed a war and
750,000 people died about that and you
know sometimes you have to send into
federal troops like I think was
Eisenhower did that to desegregate
Alabama schools that were segregated and
remember the governor said you know
segregation now segregation tomorrow
segregation forever and I forget it was
President the time he said no you're
segregating and we're sending that we're
you're integrating your schools and
we're sending in federal troops men with
guns to make sure you do it okay
sometimes you have to do that but most
of the change happens from the bottom up
of just oppressed peoples saying you
know what stop that don't do that I
don't like it when you say that you know
and it began with the n-word and just
kept expanding so there's a logic to
where we ended up today where you have
this big bin of you know
microaggressions and so on but there was
a logic to it like I'm just saying it's
hurtful to do that and most of the
effects have been good they've been
positive just you know when Ellen comes
out on her TV show that's just a little
thing there or or when South Park you
know makes fun of all different
religions you know that it gets
perspective on things humor is good
television scripts movie scripts the way
characters talked Richard Dawkins makes
this point about you could pinpoint to
the decade when a novel was written
based on the words that are used to
describe Jews blacks and women and you
know it but but no one said okay we're
gonna pass laws to say you can't use
these words to describe Jews blacks and
women we all just changed the way we
talk about other people in a way that's
more liberal that's more
all-encompassing that's more egalitarian
in that sense and and it's not clear how
exactly that happened just incrementally
a little bit by bit you know it's just
it's like trying to figure out when a
word starting to be used it's like it's
really hard 9/11 or gays and I remember
in the late 90s there was a couple of
atheists that wanted to quit you
the word atheist atheists and call us
the brights we are the brights oh and
that didn't stick yeah it was pretty
obvious but with the you know what the
antonym did the brights were the people
that believe in God they're the dims
right okay so the shims are not gonna be
fond of that so that never took off you
know by by trying to change language by
Fiat from the top down okay here's the
new rule we're all gonna use this word
that doesn't work it's just expanding
our consciousness expanding the moral
sphere just including more people in
your honorary circle of friends and
family members or honorary family
members or people that you will treat
with respect that that has been
happening just tiny bits every day a
little bit here and there and over the
decades you see it when you look back at
the numbers like Steve Pinker does but
but it's hard to pinpoint the day that
that happened
[Applause]